[Música]
no comprendía lo que estaba pasando en
esos momentos venía trabajando duro por
siete años en matlab mi emprendimiento
de enseñanza y aprendizaje de
matemáticas así es matemáticas siempre
buscando la forma de hacerlas más
atractivas más cercanas más obviamente
útiles tanto a los niños a los jóvenes a
los profesionales a las amas de casa a
los dependientes e independientes a las
personas en general
en matlab siempre subíamos vídeos de
nuestra metodología
ecuaciones triángulos situaciones para
aplicar tu razonamiento de repente
subimos uno donde interpretamos los
números que nos entregaba el ministerio
de salud sobre la pandemia del
coronavirus las vistas que tuvo ese
vídeo no eran para nada las que
normalmente teníamos cuando sacábamos
vídeos de matemáticas esos vídeos tenían
unas 100 doscientas vistas con suerte
contando a mi mamá ya sus amigas este
primer vídeo sobre el coronavirus superó
las mil vistas nos llamó la atención
claro hicimos un segundo un tercero y
cada vez más y más vistas en poco tiempo
nuestros vídeos diarios alcanzaban las
80 mil vistas habíamos logrado bajo la
coyuntura en que nos encontrábamos
llevar el lenguaje de los números a las
personas para quitar ese primer efecto
emocional que generó la pandemia que
generó se acuerdan bien verdad
e incertidumbre
pudimos generar tranquilidad
quitarnos la venda de los ojos y a
través de los números ver la luz acerca
de este terrible virus conocer nuestra
propia realidad más allá que sea buena o
mala
tranquiliza
ustedes como creen que me sentía por
supuesto estaba emocionado porque
lograba llegar entrar a muchos hogares
peruanos y además con ese lenguaje
maravilloso de los números y el
pensamiento en el que hemos estado
trabajando por tantos años en lo
personal más de 25 de mi primera clase
de matemáticas y además el negocio
maldad perú se hacía más conocido y por
supuesto mucho más demandado
pero lo que no comprendía era un efecto
adicional
inesperado uno que jamás pensé que se
daría un efecto que agradezco
enormemente adiós me haya dado el placer
de vivir
después de subir cada vídeo leía los
comentarios y esperaba algunos como qué
buen ejercicio matemático que viene
analizado este punto o el otro había de
eso sí pero cada vez más aparecían los
comentarios de aliento de agradecimiento
que se estaba dando en las personas
qué es lo que está pasando me preguntaba
recibía comentarios como profe he
perdido a mi padre me siento muy mal y
usted me ha sacado una sonrisa usted me
ha alegrado un poquito este día
comprendí que además de un medio de
información éramos un medio de
incremento del ánimo de alegría de luz
de esperanza en momento donde toda la
enfermedad y muerte
los números que son vistos como fríos y
tediosos representan situaciones
sociales en nuestras vidas no solamente
calan a nivel cognitivo sino también
emocional y desde que somos niños
existía una falta de información por
parte de las instituciones sobre el
desarrollo del coronavirus en el país
esta falta de información me unió a
otros investigadores a científicos de
gran talento y trayectoria en el perú
todos evidenciamos el gran atraso que
tenemos como país en el uso y
divulgación de la información
qué podemos hacer para mejorar en este
aspecto para hacer más investigación más
análisis más desarrollo y aplicación de
soluciones
mi respuesta es que debemos empezar por
los niños
desde que nacen los niños son expertos
en estimación y lógica resuelven
problemas y situaciones de cantidad
volumen distancia equivalencias e
inclusive las matemáticas es ese primer
lenguaje que les permite comunicarse con
el ser más importante en sus vidas su
madre y también su padre no lo crees
seguro con tus papás cuando eras muy
niño habrán visto algún perro muy grande
y seguramente habrán tomado una mayor
distancia una que estimaban segura o
seguro contaban las cucharadas que te
faltaban para terminar tu papilla no
tengo absolutamente ninguna duda que
habrá subido algunos escalones agarrado
de la mano de tu mamá y con tono de
juego habrás escuchado
los últimos estudios que se han hecho en
niños de cuatro meses de edad
demostraron que tenían el concepto de
cantidad y ha desarrollado
los adultos tenemos que entender y creer
que nuestros niños no aprenden estas
competencias en el colegio sino que ya
cuentan con las mismas prácticamente
desde que nacen son mini científicos que
quieren conocer y aprender acerca de
todo es nuestra responsabilidad
desarrollar esas competencias y
habilidades de manera correcta no ser un
obstáculo para ellos porque de las 11
dificultades que trabajamos en matlab la
primera
lamentablemente es el adulto a cargo de
la crianza del niño
si la relación de los niños con las
matemáticas es óptima qué pasa entonces
porque la mayoría de nuestros hijos
terminan quinto de media odiando las es
porque nosotros y por supuesto nuestro
sistema educativo
necesita actualizarse la pandemia global
ha hecho que ese retraso que ya teníamos
se haga más severo primero debemos hacer
las paces con las matemáticas
perdonarnos tantos momentos de
sufrimiento y recordar los momentos que
sí fuimos y somos felices dejar de
etiquetar la como aburrida inalcanzable
inútil nosotros los adultos debemos
conocer y corregir las dificultades por
las que están atravesando nuestros niños
actualmente
dificultades que nosotros les estamos
creando
seguro te dará pasado también mi hijo de
8 años dentro de poco sabrá muchísimas
cosas más de lo que yo sabía cuando
tenía 18 es por el colegio no no son los
medios digitales que si le complacen
esas ganas que tiene de experimentar de
conocer de aprender jugando que si va a
su velocidad y dirección que inclusive
lo empoderan
y aprovechando estos medios les
acercamos la matemática a nuestros niños
volviendo a las mas aplicativas más
cercana a ellos mostrándoles su papel
para su propio desarrollo para lograr
aprendizajes y experiencias para mejorar
su comunidad y su propia realidad
es de esa manera que esos futuros
adultos pondrán en agenda con tinta
indeleble el desarrollo de la
investigación del análisis y de la
aplicación de soluciones
finalmente la matemática nos dieron una
mano en los momentos más difíciles y eso
fue algo con lo que no contábamos